i i follow you on instagram now you
always seem to be having a good time
when you're going about business
uh which i think is really important
it's also really important as well
sometimes to say no to deals i know you
were looking at
um you actually sent it across to me
you're looking at buying 48 houses
it was this big thing and you were
really close to completing on it but
then in the end we just it was like
actually it's not a great deal there's a
lot of bad tenants the figures
don't quite work and it didn't tip the
boxes and you walked away from that
yeah so i think it's important to grab
life by the horns but also sometimes you
do need to say no to things
yeah yeah um talk to me a little bit
about that and why you chose not to go
there
yeah well i mean it was actually i mean
one another way you can buy a large
amount of properties is if you buy a
company you'll know that yourself goes
and that that has its i for me it has a
lot more pros than it has cons
but again it was just like it was
actually i think it was 43 properties
we actually did start to buy them and we
bought started to buy shares in the
the proper com property company that
owned them uh stewart myself
and yeah it was just after a while i was
started looking at the kind of quality
of the houses
the tenants how much attention it was
taken up and how much work it was
needing done
for what return it was profitable there
was a return
but sometimes you i felt like you have
to look at like what are you spending
your time on
and what are you getting back and
sometimes i think
people can get into something that's not
necessarily
really working that well but give a lot
of time and energy and still it
there's not can i any fruit at the end
of the day so it was
i just had to look at it and i some of
the sort of
tenant situations and you know people
smashing windows and people stealing
pipe work or whatever and i just thought
you know what like
the more higher-end property the bigger
stuff
seems to be a better quality a smoother
transaction yeah and a different sort of
people i mean for sure i mean i think
that buying 43 little houses
you'd be better off probably i said this
i said this to the time you're better
off probably doing what you have done
which is going and buying a barn and
pushing the value up or buying one
bigger property
um but that make that makes sense and
it's just great to see you
see you doing so well talk to me about
the importance in your opinion your
experience
of education because you're someone that
went to university to study business
you're someone that's done my online
training you're someone who studies and
does personal development courses and
why is that such an important part to
you and do you think that would you
advise everybody
do that or talk to me about that well i
mean education for me is
is the like absorbing a knowledge
with the idea or purpose of using that
knowledge
right so a lot of people that have
viewed and myself
are at university getting a degree or
studying
and they don't actually know where
they're going or what they're doing
so in my viewpoint that's a waste of
time and it was a waste of my time i
wasted six years in higher education
because i didn't know what i was doing
and i think you have to have a purpose
it's like when i learn when i start
looking at your stuff
i really absorb it because there's a
purpose like why am i going to use it
when i read the books like rich dad poor
dad you know pour your heart into
elon musk's latest autobiography you
know everyone hubbard's books like
this that i was starting to read the
nike book that day but i'm reading
these books with the idea that like what
are these guys doing
how what what moves they make and how
they're doing it and i'm and i'm
thinking we're using it so i would say
education would be somebody learning
stuff with the idea of using it so
like people getting degrees and stuff
but what's the point what's the purpose
now if somebody's going to be a doctor
or maybe an engineer that's got a
purpose that's got an end goal so then
yeah sure you're going to need to do
education but a lot of education i think
to be honest is is pretty much useless
especially at school as well yeah
and people spend the crazy thing is
people say oh samuel leads oh he sells
you expensive courses like hold on a
minute
the most you can spend with me on any
course is ten thousand pounds now you
might think that's a lot
but that's a lot of training all these
different courses and materials
you go to university you'll spend that a
semester yeah
and you'll to study sometimes philosophy
yeah
and then end up at mcdonald's surely
that's the scam
surely university and college and like
the idea of working 40 hours a week for
40 years to retire on 40
of what you couldn't afford to live on
in the first place and save up money and
work hard and put it in the bank for
them to get rich
and the bank will give you money for a
wedding but not for an investment that's
the scam folks
i mean as a business person what do you
think yeah a 100
agreement but people are so brainwashed
yeah that's the cult
this is people are so brainwashed well i
think i mean i get called a court people
say oh
yeah i don't think that's the majority
of society
i think the majority of people that look
at your stuff like it and yeah
a lot of the time going to university
for a degree you can't use
getting a huge amount a day and then
working up your job and then you're
stuck it's not a good model it
definitely isn't
so i think like you said the importance
of education
education is about gaining knowledge for
use
so if somebody just holds that as that's
the rule right
what why am i learning this and if they
don't know why they're learning it
they should just go and get a job like
just go and get started
and if they even want to be like
something in a large field like they
want to be
some kind of guy who owns a big company
in construction just go and start
working in construction
and build your way up and spend six
years working in construction
as your education and then you'll be
fine but don't go to unity learn
yeah i i agree and it's just so funny to
see
the system the way that people are
programmed to
think and to act and to behave i mean
the whole idea of debt the whole idea
that
we're encouraged to get bad debt yeah
bad debt but then
people then when i'm taking on good debt
yeah and talking openly about it
people accuse me of encouraging people
to get that day i'm saying no
this is good debt but then the media
and the government and the education
system and banks
are actively and the tv and the media
are actively encouraging people
yeah to take on bad debt yeah for things
like a house to live in themselves which
is a liability
for holidays for weddings for sofas
take it on now and pay for it later i'm
teaching take on a house now and pay for
it later on a lease option agreement not
take on a sofa and pay for it later and
by the time you go to pay for it
the sofa's trashed and it's gone down in
value and you still haven't got the
money like come on
you people are financially [ __ ] yeah
yeah well i i don't i don't even know if
okay when you say that it's like but
there's just no education out there on
finances
but that's why i like the stuff that you
see in particular what grant says
grant cardone speaks a lot about the
education of what money is
how finances are how you operate and
that there's good information out there
on finances as i think people just don't
have the tools and
and it's promoted heavily like get
yourself in the housing market you know
get yourself in the housing ladder like
that's pushed really
yes and if people don't aren't on the
housing
ladder they feel like they're missing
out or they're losing in life but that's
that's how it's promoted the housing
ladder is very different to what we're
talking about 100
we're talking about become a property
business entrepreneur
and buy assets yeah being on the housing
ladder
is about getting yourself stuck in the
rat race of
a mortgage but no rent because you're
living there yourself yeah
that's dead interest payments on the
house you live in that's dead money
not rent yeah 100.